[Music]
do not necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or nextar Media
Group truthfully there's no reason to
have them elected
tonight on politics now oversight at
Clark County and a neglected part of the
valley we speak with county commissioner
tick segerblum about his re-election
campaign
we need to go back to a system that
actually cares about putting drug
traffickers behind bars for good
campaigning on Law and Order Republican
Senate candidate Adam laxalt takes
questions from local reporters for the
first time in months
it seems like that I didn't get the
whole story a murderer escapes from
prison the question is how the eight
news now investigators dig into whether
the prison system kept everyone in the
dark about its errors
[Music]
from 8 news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now I'm John langlo today marks
five years since the one October
shooting at the Route 91 Country Music
Festival five years ago 58 people killed
that night on the south end of the Las
Vegas Strip the death toll later Rose to
60 hundreds more injured there was a
ceremony at the downtown healing Garden
this evening there was a 5K run downtown
tomorrow morning if you want to see our
coverage and see some stories about
survivors of this tragedy five years
later head to 8newsnow.com
in other news a convicted murderer who
escaped from the Southern Southern
desert Correctional Center is now back
in custody he was recaptured on Thursday
trying to take a bus to Tijuana but
there are still questions over why it
took so long for Nevada's prison system
to tell the public about the Escape 8
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy has
more on how local and federal law
enforcement tracked the convict down
the concern is the escaped inmate had a
four-day Head Start before police tried
catching him now the focus is how he was
able to escape in the first place and
how no one inside Nevada prisons noticed
he was missing for four days this is
Porfirio Duarte Herrero being taken into
custody last night in downtown Las Vegas
Sheriff Joe Lombardo pointing out how
dangerous the convicted killer is and
acknowledging with a case of an escaped
inmate like him this could have ended a
lot worse as we've reported sources say
the prisoner used a cardboard dummy in
his cell used acid to corrode metal to
escape out of his window and climbed
over a barbed wire fence the last time
he was accounted for in the prison was
Friday evening the Department of
Correction saying staff noticed he was
missing Tuesday Morning the question how
could this happen are you 100 confident
that the prison only realized he was
missing Tuesday morning or do you
believe anyone had knowledge he was
missing on Friday Saturday sooner than
that I don't want to guess to anything
Vanessa I I don't have confidence in any
of those questions that you just
presented we've reached out to the
Department of Corrections multiple times
for answers and have not received a
response Governor Steve ceselek is
calling for an investigation Sheriff Joe
Lombardo says he is confident the
prison's Inspector General will do a
thorough investigation now important to
note here Sheriff Joe Lombardo and
Governor Steve sisalak are running
against each other in the governor's
race Sheriff Lombardo saying as this
search was taking place no one was
playing the blame game but that question
remains how could this have happened
reporting at Metro Police Headquarters
Vanessa Murphy 8 news now all right news
now investigators not only broke the
news about this Escape hours before
officials said anything about it well
the investigators also broke news of his
capture eight news now investigator
David charns asked Governor Steve
sisolaca about the timeline
we had a prisoner who was on the loose a
convicted murderer you are the governor
of the state of Nevada and you were not
told for four days and there are members
of the prison commission you sit on who
said they found out when we published
our article before the Department of
Corrections even issued a statement I
was very upset very disappointed that
that's what happened I don't know now
they said it could have been as early as
Friday we don't know in fact when it
happened well it seemed like they lied
to you because you said something
different and then they came out about
15 minutes later and said it was
actually Friday yeah it seems like that
I didn't get the whole story all of that
is an investigation in terms of not just
what happened in terms of how it was
communicated to me and to law
enforcement and to the general public we
will get to the bottom of what happened
and appropriate action will be taken
against anybody that was involved in it
believe me do you think your own
department is working against you and
lying it's not your department but over
the department you technically oversee I
don't think you're working against me I
think that they were neglect and
negligent in some areas here
it's really an ongoing story now to that
race for governor Vanessa just mentioned
and what polls show is a very tight race
Governor says like and his Challenger
Sheriff Republican Joe Lombardo they
were on stage together earlier this week
they spoke at a construction industry
event inside Red Rock Casino questions
from the crowd range from affordable
housing issues the economy education
they were also asked about shrinking
levels in the Colorado River
it's the old joke that they made in the
west whiskeys for drinking and Waters
for fighting over and that's what we're
dealing with right now water is a
precious commodity the governor has to
have those conversations he has to push
back on his buddy Gavin Newsom and says
hey all right we you need to help us in
this aspect
I don't know the candidates did not take
questions from the media at that event
Joe Lombardo is switching his position
on an abortion related executive order
from Governor sisalak the executive
order says Nevada will not cooperate
with another state which plans to
prosecute women or doctors for an
abortion Lombardo initially said he
would repeal that order this week he
posted on his campaign website he would
not repeal it until the legislature
makes clear that Nevada will not
prosecute women or medical providers
over abortions he says his initial
position was because he thought the
order was just political theater
Republican Senate candidate Adam laxalt
campaigned with former U.N Ambassador
and South Carolina Governor Nikki Haley
earlier this week the event was over at
Dragon Ridge Country Club in Henderson
and that's where laxalt's message was
essentially he is the law order
candidate he took questions from the
media and said he would want to roll
back some democratic policies that
lessened penalties for drug convictions
like we need to go back to a system that
actually cares about putting drug
traffickers behind bars for good we need
to get rid of this no bail stuff that's
going on the reality is you have repeat
offenders there are bad people in our
communities that wake up and they
continue to commit crimes and we need to
treat them like criminals make sure the
community is protected
Nikki Haley also hosted a campaign event
with Republican gubernatorial candidate
Joe Lombardo who you just saw that would
have been on Thursday a spokesperson for
laxalt's opponent Democratic incumbent
Senator Catherine Cortez masto responded
with this quote Adam locksalt has
attacked federal law enforcement sided
with insurrectionists who went after
Capitol Police and then hit a top and
lied about it that is her reaction to
that
as we get closer to the election we are
also trying to host debates including on
that Senate race we certainly think it's
important that voters that you hear
candidates explain their ideas
there was no debate in uh when you ran
for governor there was one sort of
smallish debate when the Republican
primary for your current race
um
you obviously are attacking your
opponents each opponent opponent is
attacking each other through ads do you
think voters deserve to see yourself and
Senator Cortez masto on stage together
in an actual debate in here you guys
speak to each other absolutely so what's
we've accepted a Statewide debate with
the NBC affiliates north and south and
we've accepted a debate with the most
respected political commentator in the
state of Nevada
so Senator Catherine Cortez masto agreed
to our debate and two others in June we
are collaborating with UNLV Univision
and uh the CBS affiliate up in Reno for
Senate and gubernatorial debates those
dates would be October 18th and 20th
laxalt says he accepted two different
debates in September the Cortez masto
campaign says it turned down those
debates Sinclair another Broadcasting
Company says that it has not given them
any potential dates locations or
moderators as for our gubernatorial
debate our proposal only Governor Steve
sisalak has accepted our invitation
next Saturday though we will have a
congressional district 4 debate
Democratic incumbent Stephen horseford
and Republican Sam Peters will debate
starting at nine o'clock here on channel
8. our Vanessa Murphy and Christian
casitis will be the moderators after the
debate politics now at 11 35 will be a
post-debate breakdown with a panel
moderated by review journal politics and
government editor Steve Sebelius
Las Vegas city councilwoman Victoria
Seaman is suing fellow councilwoman
Michelle Fiore Seaman says Fiore
physically attacked her and the city
failed to stop it in her lawsuit Seaman
claims Fiore broke her finger and threw
her to the ground back in January 2021.
Seaman says she reported Fiori's
Behavior to the mayor and of the city
Seaman claims mayor Carolyn Goodman
brushed it aside and that the city
destroyed the evidence
I have been trying to get
changes in policy so this doesn't happen
to anyone else I don't ever want
somebody to be assaulted and it's
covered up and nothing is done and
there's no policy changes and that's
what we've been asking for for a long
time
city of Las Vegas says it destroys video
after 60 days even though the review
journal requested that video City
officials say the paper quote didn't
request it properly in the lawsuit
Seaman is seeking money for medical
bills and other damages she also wants
Fiore to resign but this is not the
first we're hearing of this alleged
assault here's what fiori said when I
asked her about it back in February
that physical altercation
we'll just have to see where that goes
but what I will tell you is that I would
never ever assault somebody first
both women are Republicans Fiore
currently running for state treasurer
months before his contract expires Clark
County School District superintendent Dr
Jesus jar had his performance evaluated
by the board this week the same board
which fired and rehired him last year
the first hour of the meeting was a
presentation from a trainer hired by the
school district to try and help the
board get along better trustees
discussed Dr jara's work leading the
nation's fifth largest District Danielle
Ford Linda Cavazos the trustees they
continued their criticism of Dr Jara
they claim the benchmarks used to
measure success keep being changed on
his behalf however in the end a majority
of the trustees gave him an a grade
citing the rising grades among students
next on politics now is East Las Vegas
neglected County Commissioner tick
segerblum talks about why he is focusing
on that part of the valley and that'll
be a priority if he's re-elected Plus
getting to the bottom of fraud the
investigation into how much unemployment
money was
welcome back to politics now
there are three seats on the Clark
County Commission up for re-election in
November and one is the district EC
currently held by Democratic segerblum
his District covers part of the Las
Vegas Strip in east Las Vegas his
Challengers include as you see on your
screen there Republican John Ryder
nonpartisan candidate Marco Hernandez an
independent American Party candidate
Randy Rose we started our discussion
with Mr segerblum discussing the
criminal case against County public
administrator Rob Tellis
how can you guarantee for voters that
there is enough oversight whether these
people are elected or they're appointed
enough oversight from the County
Commissioners and from you of people who
are elected to run these important
offices well again the the historically
the problem was they are elected so we
don't want to get a micromanage
something that the voters have spoken
for but obviously we need to pay more
attention going forward these were once
very small offices now they're huge
offices the tons of employees but the
other thing is truthfully there's no
reason to elect those positions they in
this day and age they should be
appointed by the County Commission and
then you can always directly responsible
there's no new fans or butts we pick the
person if there's a problem we fix it if
we don't fix it then come after us would
you consider something if you're
re-elected to maybe make those kind of
changes so it's not sort of as you're
describing you know above my pay grade
seems to be the explanation from from
you no absolutely and one of the things
we're going to do is go to the
legislature and asked to have those
positions taken out of the election
cycle there's no
we get good people historically we've
had good people but there truthfully
there's no reason to have them elected
in the county of two plus million people
no one knows who the public Guardian is
no one who's those positions are not
something where people can actually meet
them an issue that certainly is uh close
to your heart is uh legal marijuana
which is uh an ongoing issue to try and
get those pot lounges in place it's been
a bit of a slow roll the Hope was to
open it have them open in Clark County
in the summer that hasn't happened yet
where do things stand right now and what
are you hoping to try and push through
moving forward well you know I passed
the first marijuana law in 2013.
you know as soon as we passed it the
only place you could legally smoke it
was in your house which of course
um you know terrorists don't have a
house so I mean it's like Hello how are
we trying to sell marijuana to people
who can't use it and so obviously it's
been out there people using it wherever
and and illegally but um we we I
honestly can see the end of the tunnel
as the state has finally finalized their
regulations they're going to ask for
applications at the end of October we're
putting together our regulations to
match those
so when any dispensary gets a permit
they'll be able to come if they want to
be in the county they can come to the
county right away and we'll be ready to
take their application we have land use
our land use people are ready to
determine whether it's a good location
and we're going to be up and running but
it it's just amazing how long it's it's
literally been 20 23 10 years until
people could legally smoke something
which uh in my opinion never should have
been illegal moving forward if you're
elected for another four years whether
it's in the East part of the valley or
elsewhere in your District what do you
want to try and Achieve well first off I
said I want to bring the the
infrastructure to East Las Vegas that is
comparable or start at least the process
to build the interchanges to have the
freeways to have the roads so people can
get to work improve the park system I'm
actually going to create a thing with
with this travel to an overlay of so the
schools in my district where we can try
to then devote County attention to the
things the schools don't do but Focus
around the schools I've brought back the
Redevelopment agency so over here at
Maryland Parkway between Karen and
Sahara we're going to start to redevelop
that whole area which has been very
underserved so a lot of the my district
is poor a lot of it's been overlooked
for lack of reason because people want
to develop out in the southwest or
Northwest but now because of the land
shortage actually developers are
starting to come back in and look at
some of these small pieces so there's
lots we can do
um you know it's it's the focus is now I
think pushing things back into the city
which is East Las Vegas and and my
district so I'm very very excited and of
course I have part of this trip and the
strip you know we help Resort World get
open we're working on Fountain Blue
Sahara's back and revitalized so the
north part of this trip all that all
that you know they're working there
right now so I mean it's it's knock on
wood but
there's never been a time like Las Vegas
right now and and I don't see we're
cyclical so every time we think we're
we're over it we always have a hump I
don't think we're going to have that
huge downfall I mean and once the
convention business is back in place
which again has been my district then I
think that the town will do well and
when the strip beds are full then East
Las Vegas does well we have the full
interview we will have it on
8newsnow.com and we're working to speak
with other candidates for County
Commission as well here on the program M
next on the program getting to the
bottom of fraud just how much happened
during the pandemic and what Congress is
proposing is done about it get ready for
ranked Choice voting ads the big
spending from the ballot questions
backers I'll make news now
[Music]
you're watching politics now
a government Watchdog has found more
than 45 billion dollars in potential
unemployment fraud Insurance since the
pandemic here in Nevada our unemployment
office says about half the claims filed
were fraudulent George Washington law
professor Drake hagner told Congress
government is to blame
what we really have seen is that our
State Workforce agencies have been
underprepared to respond to a crisis of
this kind
joining us to talk about the widespread
unemployment fraud is our Washington D.C
correspondent Alexander Limon Alex what
were the biggest problems that allowed
so much fraud to occur
okay
well of course one major issue here is
that there are criminals fraudsters bad
actors who are out there stealing
people's identities and committing this
fraud but really what you know experts
law professors and even lawmakers on
Capitol Hill some of them what they say
the real problem is is that the
government
um wasn't able to detect and stop that
fraud when it was happening and so the
issue here is that a lot if not most
state unemployment and Workforce offices
have really just old Antiquated
computers that aren't able to detect
things that they should be detecting
things like when claims are filed in
more than one states that should be an
automatic red flag when unemployment
claims are filed under the names and
Social Security numbers of people who
are either dead or in prison again this
should be something that computer
systems should be able to detect by
cross-checking either with other states
with the i IRS with County records of
who has died and that's just something
that state unemployment system computers
were not able to do Nevada's had a
problem here our Dieter has been had its
own issues with Antiquated systems is
there an estimate of just how big the
backlog is of people who had our their
identities stolen and couldn't file at
all
you know on a nationwide basis as far as
how many were impacted but I think one
of the bigger problems here to know
about who was impacted is that a lot of
the lower income
low-wage job workers for example fast
food workers or restaurant workers or
you know people who worked at small
shops and
places that were completely shuttered by
the pandemic they were the ones who were
the most impacted in part because when
they did have their identities stolen or
when they did encounter these types of
fraud related problems they were you
know most likely the ones who didn't
have a desktop computer at home who
didn't have the resources or the
knowledge or the access to the
information to be able to report the
problem
and that was Alex Simone from Washington
D.C
get ready to see a lot more ads about
ranked Choice voting the ranked Choice
initiative is question three on your
ballot for November ad Impact says the
group Envy voters first spent seven and
a half million dollars on ads supporting
the initiative if approved it would
create an open top five primary you see
kind of what's going on on your screen
there and then there would be ranked
Choice voting for the general election
both the Republican and Democratic State
parties oppose this we have an explainer
about ranked Choice voting and how it
works on 8newsnow.com
counting by hand next on the program why
a judge okay to plan by one County to
hand count ballots in the upcoming
election
now
welcome back several counties in Nevada
will hand count ballots for the November
election this week a Carson City judge
turned down a challenge to the hand
counting from a progressive group he
said Nevada law makes voting machines
optional not required Nye County plans
to run its ballots through a voting
machine and then hand count again as
Mariela County did hand counting back in
the primary election
[Music]
this week in what to watch fighting for
your votes we're going to have a
congressional district 4 debate next
Saturday and then politics now will have
a post-debate show Democrat Stephen
horseford and Republican Sam Peters will
answer questions from our own Vanessa
Murphy and Christian causidis and the
hearing to figure out if Rob tell us the
public administrator will lose his job
that is next week the District
Attorney's Office says Telus cannot
perform his elected duties tell us right
now as you know is accused of murdering
review journal reporter Jeff gearman the
hearing for this was scheduled for this
week it's now been pushed back to next
Wednesday
those stories and a lot more next week
we thank you for joining us this week
here on politics now don't forget all
the latest political news at
8newsnow.com we're back with you next
Saturday thank you for watching take
care
[Music]
[Music]